[Music]
My name is Bang. I'm the CTO and
co-founder of a company called Source
Graph. Uh we build developer tools and
today I want to share with you some of
the observations and insights that we've
had on this sort of like emerging skill
set of how to wield coding agents.
That sound good to everyone? All right,
cool. Um, okay. So, let's check in on
the uh the the agent discourse. Uh, I
don't know if you all saw this, but a
couple days ago there were some spicy
tweets about the the efficacy of AI
coding agents or, you know, inefficacy
depending on your perspective. So, um,
Jonathan Blow, who's a really talented
developer, he basically single-handedly
coded up the indie game Braid, if you're
familiar with that. So like he's he's
kind of like god tier status in terms of
coding ability. um retweeted Alex Albert
who's also someone I respect and admire
a lot uh works at Enthropic and
basically claiming that you know all the
hype around coding agents and code in
general uh was just it is just hype
right there's no substance there um and
then there were some responses and there
was kind of a spectrum of responses too
you know we had some other uh big names
in the developer world like Jesse
Friselle she was one of the early uh
contributors maintainers of Docker she's
also really legit uh she said basically
something to the effect of like um I
think you're right. Uh but you're in
like the top 01% of programmers,
Jonathan. For the rest of us, you know,
down here in this room that aren't on
Mount Olympus, it actually helps a lot.
Um but not super helpful if you're if
you're really really good. Um but then
we also had folks like Eric uh S.
Raymond, who is like the one of the
fathers of open source, uh who had a
very spicy reply. is basically like look
I you know consider myself to be pretty
decent at programming and uh these
things help a lot. Uh and then uh the
the kind of my favorite one of this was
actually the the top a hacker news post
that was written by um uh Thomas uh uh
Tachek uh who is a a really legit
security engineer. Um some of you may
have seen this uh trending. He was he
was basically taking the opposite view
of like, you know, there's some really
smart people there who are very AI
skeptical, but they're nuts. Like, uh,
these things are really useful. Um, so I
I'm guessing if you're at this
conference, you probably lean toward
coding agents uh are substantively uh
useful and there's something there. I
don't know. Uh, just a just a guess. But
I think even within this room, there's
probably a spectrum of uh best practices
and opinions about like where agents are
good. Uh you know, whether they're
restricted to like small edits or like
front-end applications or weekend vi
coding, whether they actually work on
your production codebase. And um I think
this is just uh indicative of of the
dynamic technical landscape that that
we're in right now. And a couple months
back, I I wrote this blog post from this
guy Jeff Huntley. So Jeff was a senior
engineer at Canva at the time. And uh
his role at Canva is really interesting.
He basically went around interviewing
all the uh developers inside of Canva
using AI tools like cursor and and other
things and seeing how they're using it.
And he basically came to the conclusion
that like most people were holding it
wrong. Uh which is which is really
interesting. and he he came up with a
blog post about like all the different
antiatterns that he was seeing. Um, but
my summation of of of that blog post is
like the the number one mistake that
people are using with coding agents
right now is they're trying to use
coding agents the same way they're using
AI coding tools uh six months ago. um
and and therefore they're wrong, which
is kind of crazy because normally if
you're you know using a tool uh the the
best practices don't change in in six
months typically the things that you
learn that are good uh will still be
like present uh and and uh you know
topical and relevant 6 months uh down
the line but I think we're in a really
interesting moment in time right now and
you know why the sudden change I think
it's because uh of this step function
transition uh that we've experienced in
model capabilities in the past 6 months.
So, you know, we've we've all been
around since the dawn of generative AI,
the ancient year of uh 2020
two, right? November 2022 was when Chat
GBT launched, right? And every year uh
now, you know, this is now the year
three, you know, three after chatbt,
right? We're now living in the AI
future. Um, but I think there's already
been kind of like three distinct waves
or or eras largely driven by the
evolution of frontier model
capabilities.
Um, and the model capabilities really
dictate the uh ideal architecture uh
that that becomes dominant at the
application layer. So in the GPD3 era,
all the models were text completion
models uh which meant all the
applications that people were building
uh were these like co-pilots or
autocomplete tools. So the dominant UX
paradigm was like you type some stuff,
it types some stuff, you type some more
and that's how you would interact. Uh
and then chat GBD came along uh with
GBD3.5 which was instruct tuned to
interact like a uh a chatbot. Uh and
suddenly people realized like oh it's
not just completing the next thing I'm
talking about. I can actually ask it
questions like I can a human now. Uh and
then some other people came along. Uh we
were part of this crowd. We realized
like hey um you know what's even better
than just like asking it questions. You
can actually copy paste stuff into the
chat and say like here's some code from
my codebase use that as an example and
pattern match against that and you that
helps it generate you know a little bit
better code or less uh less fake code or
less hallucinated code than uh it did
before. And uh that basically meant that
everyone at the application layer was
building a ragbot uh in in 2023. So like
a chatbot plus a a rag retrieval engine.
But now uh I think we've entered a new
era and I don't I'm not sure if everyone
realizes it or maybe this is I don't
know like who agrees with this statement
like who thinks it's a real paradigm
shift. Okay. And then who's who here is
like ah that's a bunch of
Anyone feel free to I like Okay. Okay.
So maybe I'm maybe I could just skip
this slide. Um
so we're now living in the era of agents
and the new model capabilities uh really
dictate a new application architecture.
And so one of the things that we asked
ourselves at source graph is you know a
lot of the existing tools in the market
they were designed for the era of GPD4
and uh claude 3. So there a lot of the
application stuff uh features and UX and
UI was really built around the
capabilities or in some cases the
limitations of the chatbased LMS. Um,
and so if we were going to design a
coding agent from the ground up to
unleash the capabilities of tool using
LMS, agentic LMS, uh, what would that
look like?
Okay, so here are my spicy takes. Uh,
these are controversial design decisions
that I think are are better to make in
the age of agents. Uh, and many of these
go against the best practices that kind
of emerged in the chatbot era. Okay, so
number one is uh the agent should just
make edits to your files. It shouldn't
ask you at every turn like, "Hey, you
know, I want to make this change. Should
I apply it?" Uh if it's asking you and
it's wrong, uh it's already done the
wrong thing and it's wasted your time.
Uh humans need to get uh more out of the
inner loop and more kind of like on top
of the loop like still steering it and
guiding it, but less you know
micromanaging and and managing every
change. Second thing is do we still need
a thick client uh to uh to manipulate
the LLMs? Like do we still need a fork
VS code? That's like the salty way of
saying this, right? Um the VS code fork
became the the culmination of the AI
coding application I think for for the
the chatbot era. But there's this
question of like, you know, if the
contract of an agent is you ask it to do
stuff and then it does stuff, do you
really still need all that UI built
around like context management and
applying the proposed change in the
codebase or can you just ask it to do
stuff and expect it to to do the right
thing?
Third, I think we're going to move
beyond the choose your own model uh
phase. So I think in the chatbot era, it
was very easy to swap models in and out
and you'd like, oh, you know, a new
model came along. let me swap it out and
see how well it attends to the context
that my retrieval engine fetches. Um, in
the agentic world, there's a much deeper
coupling uh because the LLM that you're
using essentially becomes the the brains
of these agentic chains and so it's much
harder to rip and replace. And I think a
lot of people in this room who have
tried mixing and matching uh you know
different models uh in the context of
agents have found that it you know
swapping out a different model and
expecting similar results is is very
different. a lot of the like a lot of
the LMS out there aren't even good at
the basics of tool use yet. So it's it's
very difficult to just replace the
brains. Um four is I think we're going
to move past the era of fixed pricing.
Uh agents eat up a lot of tokens and so
they look expensive relative to chat
bots. Uh but the comparison that more
and more people are making is how much
human time is it saving? So they're
still cheap relative to to human time
saved. And the fixed pricing model
actually introduces a perverse incentive
now where uh it's like selling gym
memberships, right? Like if if I sold
you a membership to my chatbot and
you're now paying me, you know, 20 bucks
a month, uh my incentive now is to push
the inference cost as low as possible.
And the easiest way to do that is to use
dumber models. Um but dumber models just
waste more more of your time. Um sorry,
this is a long list. Um uh hopefully
it's not too tedious, but um I think
these are important points. Uh the the
second to last point I'll make is I
think the Unix philosophy is going to be
more powerful here than vertical
integration. So in developer tools, the
ability uh to use simple tools in ways
that compose well with other interesting
tools is really powerful. And so I think
especially with agents where there's
less of a need to create like a lot of
UI around it, you're going to start to
see more command driven tools, command
line tools and things like that. Um and
then last but not least is uh you know
we had an existing uh rag chat coding
assistant. Maybe some of you have used
it. It was called Kodi. Um it still
exists. We're still supporting it. Uh
it's still in heavy use across you know
many fortune 500 companies. uh but we
decided to build a a new application
from from the ground up for the agentic
world because we didn't want to be
constrained by all the assumptions and
constraints that uh we we built into the
application layer uh for the previous
generation of LMS.
And one analogy I like to draw here is
you know what uh the the the early days
of the internet right like in the early
days of the internet the the way people
you know jumped into the the web was
using an interface on the left. This is
before like most people knew what the
internet was about what it was capable
of and that was the right interface for
the first generation of the internet
because like what can you do with the
internet? Well like there's a bunch of
different things you can look at like
trending celebrities you can you know
buy automobiles. You can look at movie
reviews, all these things you might not
have thought of. And so it's it's useful
to have in front of you, but at some
point it gets a little tedious, like
clicking through all the different
hyperlinks and navigating your way
through. And then the the real power of
the web was sort of unleashed by just
like the one simple text box where you
just like type what you're looking for
and and you get to it. And I think, you
know, with with aentic UIs, that's what
we should be striving for both in
developer tools and in a lot of
different application paradigms. Okay,
so what does that look like in practice?
So when we went to design this thing, um
our coding agent is called AMP. Uh and
AMP has two clients and this is what
they look like. So both are like very
very bare bones. A lot of people, you
know, look at this and like what is
this? It's just a text box. What what
can I do with it? Um and and that was by
design, you know, that for all the
reasons I just mentioned. Um, one client
is just a simple VS Code extension um,
that allows us to take advantage of some
nice things that you get in in VS Code
like being able to view diffs. That's
really important in the agent decoding
world. I often joke that like that's now
I use that view more than the editor
view now. Um, and and the second was a
CLI. So, uh, just stripping things down
to bare bones. It has access to all the
same tools as the the VS Code extension
does, but it's just something that you
can invoke in your command line. You can
also script it, compose it with other
tools.
Okay. So, what what what does this
actually look like in practice? Um I I
wanted to do something a little bit
risky here, which is um in the past I've
done a lot of like, you know, hey,
here's me building a simple app, like
those sorts of demos, but I actually
wanted to show off like where we think
this is most useful, which is like, hey,
I'm working on an application that has
real users. is let me actually make a
contribution to that codebase given all
w with all the like existing
constraints. And so I actually want to
I'm just going to code a little bit. I
don't even know how far we're going to
get. Um but this is this is AMP. Uh this
is VS Code running AMP in the sidebar
and it's open to the AMP codebase. Um
and what I want to do is implement like
a simple uh change uh to this
application. So the change that I'm
going to make is AMP has a server
component and the server exists uh as a
way to provide the LM inference point.
It also provides like team
functionality. We have a way to share
like what different teams are doing or
what different users are doing with AI
so you can kind of learn from other
users. There's leaderboard. It's fun. Um
but there's also these things called
connectors which allow AMP to talk to
external services. So our issue tracker
is Linear. Um, and so I've integrated
Linear uh into AMP here, but I'm kind of
annoyed because it's using this generic
like network icon, and I would really
like to customize this icon such that
when you plug in the linear MCP
endpoint, it it uses a more appropriate
icon like a checkbox or something
issuey.
Um, so I've already filed this as a
linear issue and I'm just going to ask
uh can you find the linear issue about
customizing the linear connector icon uh
then implement it.
So what this will do is um it has access
to a set of tools. Um I can go over here
to the tool panel and see what tools it
has access to. Some are local, some are
built in. Um it's got the standard tools
like read and edit file or run bash
command. Uh you can also plug in things
like playrite and postgress via MCP. Uh
and then linear is also plugged in uh
through this. So we're basically talking
to the linear API uh through the MCP
server and uh what this will do is it
will use the linear uh issues API
um and it will search issues. It found
50 issues and the one that I was
referring to is at the top here. So add
a special icon for the linear connector.
Uh and now it's going to go and
implement uh the thing for me. Um and
one thing to note here is it's just
making these tool calls on its own. I'm
not asking it uh to use specific tools.
Um we've also tried to make the uh
information that you see uh minimal. So
like you don't need to see all the API
tool calls that it's making underneath
the hood or like crowd out the
transcript with a bunch of things. Most
of the time uh we we just want to keep
it simple because the contract we want
to provide to users is like the the the
feedback loops here are more robust and
you don't have to um micromanage this as
much. Another thing I want to point out
here is the search tool that this is
using is is actually a sub agent. So
it's actually spinning off a sub aent
loop that uses a form of agentic search.
It has access to a bunch of different
search tools. Uh keyword search, uh uh
just regular GP, uh looking up file
names. Uh if you want to inspect what
it's doing, it you can click the expand
thing and see like what different paths
it's taking, what files it's reading,
what things it uncovered. Uh but again,
by default, we think this is like an
implementation detail and hopefully it
should just surface the the right thing.
Um so it's it's working. It's gathering
context. Um, another thing I want to
call out in this interface is um, as
we've gotten more feedback, we've we've
kind of designed this thing to be more
multi-threaded. So, there's a quick
keyboard shortcut that allows you to
like quickly tab through the different
threads that you're running. And it's a
common paradigm in in our user community
to be running more than one of these
things at a time. Um, and it takes a
little bit used to get get used to the
the context switching. Like developers
hate context switching, right? Like we
like to be uh in in flow in in focus.
Um, Typically what we see here is um the
the secondary thread will either be
something that's like a lot shallower so
that you can quickly page back to the
main thread or what I like to do is
while the agent is working I actually
like to understand the code uh at a
deeper level myself so I can better
understand what what it's going to do.
So uh I could ask something like can you
show me how connectors and connections
work in AMP? I can ask it to draw a
picture of that.
So, we'll kick that kick that thread off
in parallel. We'll check back in on what
this guy is doing. So, it's found uh
it's read a bunch of files. It's read
some frontend files. Our front end is
written in spelt. Um and as you can see,
it's it's being fairly thoughtful about
reading the appropriate files before it
actually goes and and does the work. And
we find that this is really important uh
to make the feedback cycles uh more
robust. Um, otherwise the the anti
pattern is you just like get into the
weeds of like steering it manually.
Um, it's also got this to-do list thing
at the bottom uh that helps it structure
and plan out the the longer term tasks
so that it doesn't go like immediately
dive into the code. This is a classic
mistake that like human developers make
too where you like dive into the code
too early and then you get lost in the
weeds and then it takes a while to dig
yourself out.
Um, okay. So, it's making some changes.
Um, one other thing that I like to point
out here is, you know, I mentioned that
I use the diff view in VS Code now,
probably more than the editor view. Uh,
VS Code actually has a really nice diff
view. I have it hotkeyed um, so I can
open it up quickly. And most of the my
time in VS Code now is spent just like
reviewing the changes it uh, it makes.
And I actually like this a lot better
than uh, like GitHub PRs or uh, git diff
on the command line just because it's in
the editor. you can see the whole file
and uh jump to definition uh even works.
Um so yeah, we'll we'll just wait a
little bit for it to to do its thing. I
actually think it's it's probably made
looks like it's getting it's getting
there. Um let's it's probably just
running like tests. Let's see if we go
back here if it's updated the icon at
all.
Okay, so it hasn't gotten there yet, but
I think it's on the right track.
Does it write its own test? Uh, the
question was, does it write its own
tests? Yes, it typically writes its own
tests. And if if it doesn't, you can
prompt it to to do so. So, uh, it's
doing a lot of things. It's reading a
lot of files. It's making these edits
incrementally and then checking the
diagnostics.
Um, and then now let's see if it works.
Okay, cool. So you see here the icon has
been updated and this is without me
really steering it in in any fashion. Um
notice here on this page that this icon
didn't update though. Um and so this is
actually not surprising to me because
this change as many changes in
production code bases are often more
nuanced than it seems at the surface. So
in this case, the reason it's not
getting it here is because
uh this is the admin page and the piece
of data we need to know uh we need to
read in order to tell that this is a
linear MCP uh rather than a generic MCP
is actually part of the config. We have
to look at the endpoint of the MCP URL.
In order to do that, you have to read
the config, but the config might also
contain secrets. Doesn't contain secrets
in this case, but might contain secrets
in other cases. So, we actually prohibit
those secrets from being sent to
non-admin pages. Um, so it's not
surprising to me that like the first
pass it didn't get that right, but let's
see if it can get like I'll just nudge
it a little bit. So, like uh I noticed
that the icon changed
on admin connections but not on
settings.
Um,
can you investigate why?
And uh in the interest of time, we'll
check back on this later. How about
that? Uh we we'll let it run and we'll
we'll see if if it can find its way to
the right solution there. Um
is it okay if I go a little bit over
since we started a little bit? Okay,
cool. Is it okay with you all if I go a
little bit over? Okay. Are we still
having fun? Okay, cool. So, that was
like a brief demo of just like the
interaction patterns and and the UI. We
try to keep it really minimal. Um, we've
released this to like a small group so
far. Uh, the the signup is now publicly
open. It's been open for about two
weeks, but we haven't done a lot of like
marketing around it and and that's kind
of been intentional because we're really
trying to design this for where we think
the the puck is going. And so, we've
we've done a lot to curate this
community of people who are trying to
experiment with LMS and figure out like
how the interaction paradigms are going
to change over the next 6 to 12 months.
And so our user community is really
people who are like spending nights and
weekends uh a lot of time with this
thing to see what they can get it to do.
And so actually one of the the most
insightful things and actually the main
topic of of this talk is lessons that
we've learned from just like looking at
what our power users are doing and
seeing what interesting behavior
patterns uh they're kind of like
implementing. Um and so like the average
spend uh for agents is is growing. It's
a lot more than the average spend was
for chat bots or or autocomplete. But
one other interesting thing that we've
noticed among the user base is that uh
there's a huge variance in terms of how
much people use this thing. Um to the
point where like there there's like an
upper echelon of users that are spending
like thousands of dollars per month uh
just in inference costs. And at first
we're like this has got to be abuse,
right? like someone out there is, you
know, poked uh, you know, found some way
to exploit the inference endpoint is is
using it to power some like Chinese uh,
you know, AI girlfriend or whatever. But
actually, no, when we when we spoke to
uh, the people using it, we actually
found that they were doing real things
and we're like, hm, that's interesting.
What the hell are you doing? Um and from
those insights and the conversations we
basically uh have encapsulated a series
of like best practices or emergent um
like power user patterns uh for how the
the very you know uh dominant users the
the most active users are are using this
thing and this has informed our our
product design process as well. So one
of the the first changes that we made um
was we noticed that a lot of the power
users were very writing very long
prompts. It was not like the simple kind
of like Google style like three keywords
and just like uh read my mind and expect
something good to happen. Uh they
actually wanted to write a lot of detail
because they realized that LMS are
actually quite programmable. If you give
them a lot of context, they will follow
those instructions and get further than
if you just give them like a oneline
sentence. And so we made the default
behavior of the enter key in the AMP
input just new line. So you have to hit
command enter to submit. And this throws
a lot of the new users off because
they're like, "Wait a minute, why isn't
it just enter?" like you know if I'm in
like cursor or whatever I just enter
that's easy that's intuitive but
actually what we want to push users to
do is to write those longer prompts
because that actually yields better
results and I think that's one of the
things that prevents people uh who are
still in the kind of like chat LLM uh
mode from from unlocking some of the you
know cool stuff that that agents can do.
Um, another thing that people do very
intentionally is direct the agent to
look at relevant context and feedback
mechanisms. So, you know, context was
very important in the chatbot uh era.
It's still important in the agentic era.
Now, agents do have a good good amount
of like built-in knowledge for how to
use tools to acquire context. Like you
saw that before when it was using the
search tool to find different things um
and and it was executing the test to and
and uh llinters to see if uh the code
was valid.
Um, but there's still some cases,
especially in production code bases
where it's like, oh, we do things in a
very specific way that are kind of like
out of distribution and and so like some
like less uh less agentically inclined
users at that point will just give up.
They're like ah, you know, agents aren't
capable of working with like backend
code yet. But what we've noticed is the
power user like actually let me try to
just tell it how to run, you know, the
build in this particular subdirectory or
run the tests. and that helps it
complete the feedback loop so that it
can get the validation to get further.
Um, feedback loops are going to be a big
theme of of this talk. So, another like
dominant uh paradigm here is
constructing these like front-end
feedback loops. So, like a really common
formula is you have the playright MCP
server and then there's a thing called
storybook which is basically a way to
encapsulate or componentize a lot of
your front end components. It makes it
very easy to test individual components
without loading your entire app. And you
know, you probably should have been
doing this anyways as a human developer
because you get a fast feedback loop.
You make a change, see it reflected
instantly. You get the auto reload and
then go back to your editor. But with
agents, you you kind of notice it more
because you're no longer like in the
weeds doing the thing. You're like, oh,
you're you're almost like the developer
experience engineer for your agent. It's
like, how can I make it loop back
faster? And so what the agent will do is
like, you know, make the code change,
use playrite to open up the page in the
browser, snapshot it, uh, uh, and then
loop back on itself. And it does that
via storybook because it's much faster
than reloading the the entire app.
You you put right as a tool for you.
Yes. So it's um, one of the default
recommended tools. So it's right here.
Um, and actually it looks like looks
like that run completed. I wonder if uh
it looks like it did approximately the
right thing. Um sorry, just to jump out
of the sides of her a little bit. So now
you can see like the icon is is
customized on the settings page, not
just the admin page. And if you look at
how it did that, I think it did the
right thing. So if you look at the diff,
um it actually looked at the surrounding
code and was like, "Oh, there is an
existing mechanism for plumbing
non-secret parts of the config through
to the UI. let me kind of like use that
as a reference point. And it actually
plumbed exactly that like uh field
through to the front end. So now if I
add like additional fields to the MCP
config that do contain secrets, uh it
this is like whitelisted. So it'll still
only send the endpoint URL over to the
client. You know, basically what it
needs to make that icon customization.
Um, so yeah, I know like you know it's
not a super impressively visual change
but like a lot of such changes in in
messy production code bases are like
that and it's cool to see the agent uh
be able to tease tease out that nuance.
Um,
okay. I know we're we're a little bit
over time. Can I people mind if I keep
going or uh Okay, cool.
[Laughter]
Um, there's uh some additional uh tips
and tricks. Most of this talk is just
like sharing what we've learned from our
power users. So another thing that we've
noticed is like there's this kind of
this prevailing narrative that like you
know agents are going to make
programmers lazy. It's going to make it
so we don't really understand what what
what's going on in the code. So we're
going to ship more slop. But we've
actually found the inverse happen uh
with with the power users. They're
actually using agents to better
understand uh the code. And so this is a
really good onboarding tool. Like we
just hired this guy Tyler Bruno. He's a
very precocious young developer. He's
actually still in college, but he's
working full-time in addition to taking
classes. Uh, so really bright, but also,
you know, a bit green. Um, he's been
using AMP to just like quickly ramp up
on how the different pieces connect
together. Uh, and it could draw diagrams
and and point you to specific pieces of
the code. And, uh, it's really good at
accelerating that. And then a correlary
to this is like, you know, we all do a
form of onboarding to new code whenever
we do a code review. Like, by
definition, code review is is new code.
And often times it's new code that
contains bugs or is hard to understand
or is a bit of a slog. Um and so rather
than just you know ignore the code that
the AI generates and just commit it
blindly uh we find that our user base is
actually using this tool to do more
thorough code reviews. So like I've
adopted this practice myself where if I
have to review a very large diff the
first thing I do is ask the agent to
consume the diff and generate a high
level summary so I can have like a high
level awareness and then I ask it like
hey if you were a smart senior dev
what's the entry point into this PR
because like often half the time half
the battle is just like finding the
right entry point and uh psychologically
I I often put off code reviews because
I'm like oh it's going to be a pain and
it's going to take forever just to like
figure out where I should start
reviewing it so I'll just it tomorrow.
But this thing just like it helps lower
that activation energy and and make code
reviews more thorough and and actually
uh dare I say like a little bit fun and
enjoyable now.
Um sub aents are also things. So uh we
implemented uh the search tool as a sub
aent uh in the very beginning but we're
seeing more and more uh use cases emerge
for sub aents and the general best
practice with sub aents uh is that they
often are useful for longer uh more
complex tasks because the sub aent
allows you to essentially preserve the
context window. So like the the the
quality of the LLM will degrade uh over
time. You know, Sonnet 4 has a context
window of 200K, but we see degradation
typically around like 120 or 130K, and
by the time you get hit 170 tokens, uh
it you start to see more kind of like
off the rails and crazy behavior. Uh but
sub aents allow you to encapsulate uh
the context used up by a specific
subtask like implementing a small
feature uh such that it doesn't pollute
the the main agent.
Okay, so that was a quick tour of of uh
a lot of best practices. Just to recap
like the anti practices, uh the common
anti patterns are just like
micromanaging the agent, like using it
like you would a chatbot where you have
to kind of like steer at every
interaction or review every edit it's
making. Um another common uh antiattern
is just like underprompting. So not
giving it enough detail. Like LMS their
knowledge comes from two places. It
either comes from their training data or
from the context that you give it. And
so, uh, you know, it's fine if you do a
fiveword prompt if you're coding up like
a 3D Flappy Bird game from scratch
because that's well represented in the
training set. They're really good at
that. They're trained to do that. Um,
but if you're trying to make a subtle
nuance change to your large existing
codebase, you should be giving it all
the details that you would give a
colleague on the team uh uh to point
them in the right direction. And then
last but not least, like agents are are
not a vehicle to like TLDDR the code. If
anything, they're the opposite. You
should be using them to do much more
thorough code reviews more quickly. Uh
the human is still you're ultimately
responsible for the code that you ship
and you shouldn't view this as a human
replacement. It's really a tool that you
can wield to make yourself uh 10 100x
more effective.
Uh last tidbit. So one of the things
that we've noticed among the very very
very top 1% of the 1% is uh this this uh
inclination to run multiple of these
things in parallel. So uh Jeff Huntley
who wrote that blog post uh that I I
showed earlier um he started putting out
these uh Twitter uh streams. They're
about like four hours long each and it's
basically just uh what he's he's working
on like a compiler on the side. And what
he does is he he uh constructs prompts
for like three or four different agents
to to work on different parts of of the
compiler. Uh and he's gotten to the
point where he's prompting it such that
he feels confident enough in the
feedback loops where he just like hits
enter, lets him run, and then goes to
sleep. And then like this thing just
runs on Twitter for a while. And I think
he's doing this to kind of like spread
the word. It's like hey you can use this
for serious engineering engineering like
compilers are not some like vibe coding
uh vibecoded weekend project they're
they're real tech they're they're
difficult to build um and it is possible
to use agents for for code like this but
it has to be a very intentional skill
that that you you practice and so I
think it's cool I think like there's a
lot of people thinking in terms of like
agent fleets and where the the world is
going but I I do think that the way that
we'll actually get there is by like
building these like composable building
blocks that allow people like Jeff to go
and like combine them and and uh come up
with interesting UIs. I think this is
just running in like T-Mox or some
window manager.
Okay, so like the takeaways I just want
to leave you with is one, you know,
contrary to what some might say and you
know, look, there's a lot of smart
senior developers out there who think AI
is overhyped and maybe parts of it are,
but like I think coding agents are very
real and it is uh I think a high ceiling
skill. It's like I think we will
probably invest in learning how to use
these things in the same way that we
invest in learning how best to use our
editor or our programming language of
choice. And I think the only way you can
learn this stuff is is by doing it and
then sharing it out with others. Uh and
one of the reasons we built the kind of
like thread sharing mechanism into AMP
is to help encourage knowledge
dissemination so that like if you
discover an interesting way of of using
it, you can share that out with your
team. Um but yeah, that's it. If you
want to kind of like see a recap of the
best practices in this talk, we've
actually put out like a an AMP owners
manual that guides new users how to to
best use it. Um, I'll also be around
afterwards. We have a booth in the main
expo hall. Uh, I'm supposed to say too,
if you stop by the booth, we'll give you
like $10 in in free credits. So, if
anything you saw here was of interest of
you and you want to try this out, um,
stop by and and say hi.
I noticed you still type can you and
then you correct your uh typos which I
guess you said you shouldn't do. Yeah, I
habit. I it's it's part habit and it's
part paranoia that in like a live demo
setting there will be some uh typo token
that will trigger off the rails
behavior. But it like I think that was
more of a concern that I learned in like
2023 when it actually mattered cuz like
these days LM are are more and more like
typo robust I would say.
[Music]